hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast Big Data and the learning
healthcare system practical applications
for the clinical laboratory
I'm Robert Castellanos of laberd's and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab groups the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and may encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge a slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing our
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar and that's also free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Lee
Schroeder
dr. Fodor is currently an assistant
professor at the University of Michigan
where he is director a point-of-care
testing and associate director of
chemical pathology his academic focus is
at the interface of clinical informatics
and health services research using
decision analytic approaches to model
and improve the impact of laboratory
medicine
this has included research involving
laboratory capacity and quality
improvement of sub-saharan African
laboratories modeling the impact of
different testing algorithms on health
outcomes and data mining the electronic
medical record to better understand the
performance of the point of care testing
leet Schroeder completed his BA in
physics at the University of
Pennsylvania in 1995 his MD PhD with an
NIH medical scientist training program
scholarship award at the University of
Southern California San Diego in 2011
and his pathology residency Stanford
University in 2014 Lee currently serves
as co-director of a Blue Cross Blue
Shield funded pilot program to improve
utilization of genetic testing for
hereditary cancer syndromes and is a
member of the chemistry resource
committee at the College of American
Pathologists
for his presentation I think we're all
familiar with what this cartoon is
trying to convey a lot of effort has
gone into putting data into electronic
health record and its really useful
obviously for very many reasons but it's
not quite it's really hard to get
interesting data the hope is that
electronic health records will make it
possible to develop institutions to
improve the measure of patient
and I guess this is as good of a time as
any to talk about what Big Data is and
of course it's large in size and in
sometimes it's defined as datasets that
are a little too large or maybe a killer
to use traditional tools like
spreadsheet it's also um typically messy
data data that is what used to get
thrown out right but maybe you can do
something with this and you know so it's
not an RCT but there's still information
there and and I pick out so it's defined
somewhat in the questions you ask that
you get big enough data sets tickets are
asking on new and interesting questions
you know question is like predicting
readmission rate or chance of
readmission of a patient or maybe trying
to glean off label use of medication
medical records so the idea of using big
data is this needs to change and you
know one of the commonly on the common
statistics is that it takes 17 years
before positive research results are
implemented in practice and
evidence-based medicine has been based
on the randomized clinical trial and of
course it will continue to be but the
problems with with the RCTs are that
they're expensive
there's narrow inclusion criteria
limiting generalizability of the study
findings in personalized care and in the
end guidelines are based on our thinking
too much but even in cardiology only 19%
of the guidelines are based on
randomized trial so the learning a
health care system I think is summed up
by these Tuesday minutes one
to actively learn the vast array of
routine patient management decisions
occurring every day in the hospital
don't throw it away
and also use the EMR as a decision
support tool the personalized medicine
to your population so I did my training
at Stanford in pathology and there is
this excellent example of learning
healthcare system they're published but
I started with a 13 year old patient
with with lupus admitted with the
product range proteinuria
antiphospholipid antibodies and
pancreatitis and although
anticoagulation is not standard practice
for children with lupus even when
they're critically ill with these risk
factors was that enough to anticoagulate
and there was mixed opinion among the
faculty well the lead author on this
paper and the provider and the patient
turned out informatics and so she was
bats out with what Stanford put together
in their clinical data warehouse they
had they had annotated their the textual
no medical term actually a hierarchical
ontology of biomedical terms you could
easily search through the records so
this provider simply counted up how many
patients were like hers in the medical
record and she found 98 and and and then
and she found that 10 of them and ended
up getting thrombosis during their stay
then she went through and counted up
well how many of them look just like my
patients are with having heavy
proteinuria or antiphospholipid
antibodies or pancreatitis and simply
counting up historically she's able to
calculate relative risk associated each
of these risk factors for the population
of Stanford and with that data excited
they clearly needed to anticoagulate
which they did and what was interesting
is all this work was done in less than
four hours by a single clinician which
which is really great it's not much time
but it's huge amount of time right for
regular patient care and and so that's
when actually named shahi
in annotating the clinical data
warehouse but him and others publishes
I'm phone show op-ed and health affairs
and the idea was that there should be a
button right a green button that a
provider could use to aggregate the data
and a health record in electronic health
records with a push of a button and
immediately see historically what a
patient management decisions how they
resulted three patients like yours well
we're not there yet by any means but
there's certainly big data activity and
health care so groups are using records
predicted mission which is important of
course with paper performance
compensation discovery biomarkers
looking at drug interactions Rockley we
use
the Pittsburgh health data alliance so
this is a University of Pittsburgh
Medical Center collaboration they're
incorporating medical insurance records
wearable sensors genetic data and social
media to predict an optimal management
Apple and IBM have a recent
collaboration to take iPhone Apple watch
data analyze it Watson and you know but
we're talking about the clinical
Diagnostics right now and so there's a
recent partnership between quest
diagnostics and vivo analytics company
to create decision support for
physicians the request is offering up
twenty billion laboratory results and
they're going to try to you know
identify patient to my benefit therapies
like the pcsk9 inhibitors and says
statin or identify those rare diseases
who might benefit more from drugs so
that's exciting now the tools you're
going to need I think we need to comment
and that's because the definition a big
data and some sense is not using
traditional tools and and there's a
couple open source options which are
becoming the dominant options one is are
using are just for programming
environment and I highly recommend this
it's open source free there are packages
constantly created by statisticians so
the latest
it's can be easily plugged in and it's a
very approachable language scripting
language python is a little bit more
basic and approach you can do it's got a
lot more flexibility and a percenters
excel another commercial products which
spreadsheet so what I want to take you
through today is a few examples of
mining the laboratory information system
electronic health record from the
perspective of the clinical laboratory
and this can include reference range
generation looking at coded data panel
I'm trying to evaluate accuracy of
poincare instrumentation looking at
analysis and doing some modeling to try
to synthesize the information you might
so this is a great paper detailing the
history of the reference range the
reference intervals and it's you know
laboratory results now even with the
fanciest decision to support tools and
artificial intelligence expert system is
probably the most important decision
support tool in healthcare and most
commonly use is the humble reference
interval and but there's some problems
with it so guidelines typically
recommend 120 patients per subgroup you
want to look at and yes that's
burdensome you have to identify 120
healthy patients and if you look at
different age groups and the number can
not quickly a blast amount of control
now what I want to talk about is
auto-generating these reference ranges
using data from the medical record and
why would that be useful well probably
the most immediate use we would be for
analyze in which there is no reference
range
it is often the case in Pediatrics where
the reference range is probably changing
quite often as they grow older and it's
hard to get healthy pediatric samples so
there's just not a lot of reference
ranges and it's so that could be a
really great low-hanging fruit reference
interval generation of EMR another thing
is to normalize institution specific
instrumentation population so a lot of
times one needs to just verify someone
else's reference range for for their
their application sometimes it's not
even using the same instrument so if you
use your own data and your own
population and you know we think now
medicine graphics will possibly have
different reference ranges that's the
case with creatinine and that's that's
seen in calculations for estimated
regular filtration rate so the data
mining approach for reference interval
calculation there's two primary
approaches so one our indirect
approaches these are purely statistical
where for instance if you take some
central percentages may be replied out a
cumulative or a CDF and look for the
linear range of distribution function
and that's that's not consistent with
international federation or clinical
chemistry or clsi guidelines which say
evening to explicitly state which
patients you're executing and the
statistical approach you don't do that
so the other option is to a posteriori
method and what you explicitly identify
exclusion criteria and then remove icd-9
code
remove patients who have the icd-9 code
so here's a study of innate posterior
method for hemoglobin we're expert panel
got together identified a bunch of icd-9
code that should be it's a huge list
it's a lot of work they find this some
things right so it's not ideal but it is
an approach well when I was at Stanford
so this is work done by Sarah Pugh who's
grad student there and Nick and Sean's
lab and so I was involved in this
project of automatically generating
reference ranges from their stride and
clinical data warehouse the idea is that
let's say you're looking at hemoglobin
so you query for your hemoglobin values
as well as all the icd-9 code for all
the encounters for each patient then you
identify outliers the distribution of
hemoglobin values and and see if there
are any enriched icd-9 code in those
outliers and if there are some icd-9
codes a happy present more often those
outliers will you remove remove all
those patients with that code and then
rerun the script the algorithm that are
going to be mystical and now you've got
your essentially automated a posteriori
method and then it's cleaned up group
the central 95 percent as your reference
interval so we wanted to test this out
on hemoglobin which we knew is going to
be taught because everyone knows most
hospital patients are bitten and it was
really a challenge of the system and so
we compared ourselves to a Mayo Clinic
study and a posterior associated with
bottom left and in the limit algorithm
created probably something like 50 codes
here the top 10 the first ten that came
out and and then we generated the
central 95 percent from the population
and and here it's comparing the results
of limit with both with the blue which
is the currently use interval and you
can see looking at this that the forms
pretty well both the the may approach
and and limit tended to be lower
showing that anemia but the automated
metric performs pretty well now this is
the challenge of it with hemoglobin and
so on the left you can see if you look
at the dotted line that's the
distribution of hemoglobin is from the
Mayo study before they excluded and then
after they excluded it the solid line
you can see it shift it to the right
which is they're basically excluding a
lot of patients which is good and using
a limit we see a similar thing right
where you're you're enriching for this
population that's normal first of all we
end up with something looking more like
a bell curve which is nice and and it's
doing the best Academy if you if you
look the intervals for hemoglobin and
mailed adult males up to seventeen and a
half is normal and there's hardly any
patients up there so it's nearly
basically impossible or the reference
range to go up to seventeen and a half
which is why in the end we didn't go
that high but that rhythm did an
excellent job where you're asking of it
and there's something else is to be said
I think instead of calling everyone
anemic in the hospital to say well
here's our reference range for
hemoglobin or
my patient and if your patient is in
this range that's pretty normal
there below it then they're certainly an
outlier now we did it of course for some
other analyte sodium potassium and here
we're comparing the red which is the
limit interval with some other
international correlation and one thing
you can do with this which I think can
be pretty interesting is you can reverse
it so what we did originally would be
ask given an outline hemoglobin value or
not like outline test value which I to
deny ons are associated with it we can
flip it around no we have this data and
say well given these icd-9 codes which
tests are likely to be abnormal and that
can be the basis of a decision support
tool ordering all right so now I want to
talk about encoded data in routine
laboratory panels and so obviously in
the era of personalized and precision
medicine integrating is the slide from
Uli's he's a director of pathology
informatics here at University of
Michigan and you know down on the bottom
left
it's a single hand line one data element
that's something a provider can look at
and make inferences from he gets a basic
metabolic panel the chem seven now
there's seven elements and you can glean
certain relationship like you can look
at the electrolytes in calculating you
know that VLAN and creatinine are going
to be related to help you determine the
preview or renal failure and but there's
probably other relationships you may be
missing and and certainly after that you
get the comprehensive piano and the CBC
and
it's it's far too complicated or
pattern-recognition cognitively and at
some point you're at the supercomputing
threshold and I want to show you this
this is a creates a correlation matrix
so this this is looking at the cup it's
a metabolic panel and it's all the
analytes in the panel are both rows and
column and then if there's a strong
correlation positive correlation if you
blue so of course the diagonal is all
positive that's comparing with itself
and you can see that for instance the
total protein is correlated pretty well
globulin which makes sense that
creatinine and B land is correlated
pretty strongly alt and ast very
strongly so we have chloride correlated
for charge balance but then after that
there's not a lot of correlation and and
it's actually good because you want to
have a lot of independent measurements
tell you the same thing but what this
will tell you is that there's a small
subgroup where there's a relationship a
correlation between values that would
help you identify diagnosed them you
wouldn't necessarily see it here it's
not a relationship everyone and so
that's what what you'll police and his
colleagues attempted to do or by
appearing metabolites indication so this
idea of encoded data is that there are
these hidden relationship that you might
not pick up so laboratory bound of these
effects at least 1.6 million individuals
in the US and severe refractory disease
typically treated with biologics which
are very expensive or appearing analogs
which are less expensive but they're
very difficult to manage and the best
approach ring now is to follow with by
appearing metabolites 60 g n6 an MP but
diagnostic performances are very
questionable and they're still pretty
pricey
so there is a strong motivation to
develop and improve caps for clinical
management of the IBD patients so they
went to machine learning algorithms
there are several to choose from and
they're coming a couple classifications
but it basically is unsupervised and
supervise it unsupervised you don't
provide any any labels on your patient
data cluster your data to groups and
then they're supervised approaches in
which you do label your patients those
with response with IBD curing analogues
or
and then you create a model and tried to
take patterns to classify those two
groups properly so they chose a random
forest algorithm which is a commonly
used algorithm and the idea here is that
you start with a decision tree a single
decision tree and you train on a single
decision tree and notice to say at the
first node maybe there's a sodium after
sodium is less than 130 go to the left
that's greater than 130 go to the right
and then the next step maybe you look at
potassium in it greater than 5.5 you go
to the left and you can go back to
sodium after that or incorporate any
number of analytes but then you do this
on a multitude of trees and then
essentially let them vote to classify
the next patient after you train the
data
so it turns out the algorithm works very
well
so they called it thiamine which is
thiopurine the tablet monitoring and you
can see on the left first of all there's
a rocker right and so that gives you a
sense of how accurate your tool is now
60 GN is the current tool for predicting
clinical response that your analog you
can see here it performs actually quite
poorly with the area under the curve of
0.6 so if you're at 0.5 you're talking
about a coin flip no information there
so it's better than half but not much
and then diamond is performing with the
curve and the other thing you can get
out of these models you know these are
all the different analytes on the right
that were included in the random forests
and it was the random force will tell
you which were the most which predictors
are most important as you can see well
it's neutrophils of use information
Alcott's rtw red cell growth age white
counts and so you get some sense of what
the algorithm is doing but what's really
powerful about the random forest model
is that it automatically and implicitly
looks for interactions between the terms
and and that's that's really what makes
it powerful so you know making the model
is one thing but actually integrating it
into clinical care is entirely another
one and they've successfully done this
so they're doing a machine learning
modeling to CBC in the conference and
metabolic panel now the first thing they
do is they they integrate the laboratory
information system orders with routine
patient s day so what that means is that
a CBC and the cops are constantly
monitored for new pair events and that's
story
in database then if the diamond is
ordered it triggers this computational
assay on these paired events the
analysis occurs on a laboratory
information system attached to our
server and then that's where the random
forest algorithm generates a
computational report which is returned
to both the lis and a web services layer
so that a provider can get a result like
this so you see here on the right this
is the result
and so the middle here you see that
there's a prediction of the clinical
response so in this case the probability
of clinical response is 31 percent
probability of shunting and you get this
information out of it and it's been used
now for several years and now he's
exploring the youth use of data from
generated other institutions so you can
take a CBC and kind of coming from
another institution that uses slightly
different reference ranges normalize
those reference ranges and then still
use the same algorithm okay so another
thing I'd like to talk about is
point-of-care ancient accuracy so being
a director of point of care testing here
certainly comes up all the time is
quality so there is this this great
survey that can and by far they voted so
in quality is particularly important
point of care testing since the central
lab is always an option can use it and
you know so yes you get some benefit of
reduced turnaround times immediate
management changes and so forth and
point of care testing but you can't
trust your results then
not worth it so meaningful use the FDA
in 2007 the FDA Amendments Act directed
the FDA to leverage existing information
technology to develop more active post
market surveillance for device so
basically there's quite a bit of huge
hurdles to get a device through the FDA
not currently but then after that the
post market surveillance is kind of
there's a the mod there's the mod event
reporting database so if you think that
an adverse event caused by diagnostic
passive in a complaint but there's no
active surveillance so I want to talk
about how we can accomplish this to
remind you the electronic record so we
actually use quite a bit of point of
care testing at University of Michigan
on the bottom there you can see all the
different devices we have and there's
about a million tests performed year and
so you know some of these instruments
the same time people are ordering
central lab tests and we have to match
up in time someone ordered both the
central lab glucose and in performed
well that's an opportunity for an
accuracy study so they're throwing their
data away when I look at it so this it's
an idea is to find these coins mint
testing event so along the top you can
see that in this timeline that I'm just
depicting that you have several
point-of-care tests occurring for
instance in ICU and occasionally there
is a central laboratory test sometimes
they match up and sometimes they don't
match up and in the case of glucose and
ICU
you know sometimes the situation might
be that they're the unexpected point of
cake because results and any assignment
laughs but but often I think more than
not sort of random when they match up or
easier or both at the same time they get
the material and they match up quite
often and we identify all these
coincident advance by mining your
laboratory information system and then
we perform a bunch of filters and we
want to clean the data up as much as
possible so that's down here so we
wanted to limit for the lab turnaround
time because we knew that there might be
continued glycolysis for those samples
that are taken our to to get to the
central lab for testing is the red cell
to continue and we also want to come
limit by location in some locations we
also wanted to limit to a time period
you know remove the long term variation
we also limited retesting we figured
that those cases something may have gone
wrong it identified and maybe there was
contamination and they also pulled data
to know which patients had purple line
more likely to use the line rather than
use a finger stick and we currently
don't have we don't know which ones are
explicitly finger sticks or arterial or
venous samples so after filtering we end
up with the data set and and then we can
perform an accuracy evaluation so in a
traditional study you're looking at
about on the Left maybe 200 event which
is a pretty big laboratory study well
using this method we ended up with about
20,000 events using the minimal amount
of filters a huge number right and when
you get two orders of magnitude more
data point because they're asking
different questions
or granular level and so I just wanted
to to point out some of the effects of
the filtering so on the left you can see
here these are all the different filters
that we were applying sequentially and
then you can see as we did that what the
impact was I'm biased
so think about bias first we wanted to
make it a gold standard so one gold
standard was the laboratory validation
study we perform which is about 200 or
so events and another one is we had
nurses nice you identify which events
which paired events could be used for
the study because we know that they
didn't in few dextrose or insulin in
between the two sample draws you know
because we found events that were
coincident time but maybe they were
separated by five minutes and time
stamps aren't perfect anyway so that was
our gold standard and then you can see
here detect and in sort of burnt orange
perform very well very similarly to both
of the other studies and there really
wasn't much of a difference as you added
more and more filters but with the
random air which with imprecision as
well as the patient specific
interferences you can see that detect
the imprecision or the random error
proved quite a bit as you add more and
more filters it matched up eventually
with the bedside I see you study the lab
validation study was always a bit better
which you'd expect there's a lot less
variation to instruments were used and
two people performed and then you know
on the right side it gives you and this
is the kind of thing we can start to ask
me of so much data we can look at bias
and random air across the entire range
of central laboratory glucose value if
you start to look and see the extremes
how does the accuracy change and then
here's some other analyses we can run so
the top left in panel a what that is
looking at is the time it took to get
from the bedside
to the lab central lab if we think
during that time period they're probably
going to be some glycolysis and on that
y-axis is this is basically a planned
Altman the y-axis is the point-of-care
result - the central lab result so it's
the arrow point of care test but
actually in this case is the area of the
control lab since it's the central lab
that's experiencing the glycolysis so
you can see here that over a two-hour
period there's a shift of about ten
MiG's per deciliter so it's five MiG's
per deciliter per hour which are
consistent with traditional estimates
over time so we subtracted by looking at
and we had enough data and panel t to
look at that exact effect but do it by
glucose value and there was a sense in
the literature that this effect was
worse as you got higher so getting this
huge amount of data allows the
fine-grained characterization of
accuracy and you know we could ask other
things like we regress it's kind of
watched out immature but we regressed
the air so the point of your instrument
against a bunch of physiological
parameters as codified in different
laboratory analytes and so what we did
was we looked at what is the range of
the given analyte you might expect them
on patients and if you were to shoot
that much how much of a bias when you
see your point of care meter and so
that's what we're seeing here the top
you see stuff like analytes like
hemoglobin which we know is a problem
causing about 50% shift and others like
the oxygenation actually from blood-gas
interpretation which may interfere with
redox reactions so you know these are
the types of studies you can perform and
what they haven't done yet is looking at
the impact interference medication of
course that's my main concern and this
is basically the green button for point
of care quality at our ongoing
continuous quality management and you
can basically automate this to show the
Holies parent event for all of your
instruments probably half of our testing
but you see plenty of data or other
instruments as well hold it for they are
20 K 1c and this is one where we're
interested in it because FDA submission
of a point-of-care instrument for a1c
the waited for map of wave for diagnosis
which is a step up from monitoring and
looking at what our accuracy was that's
a bit more variation there than we were
expecting to see flag for us we're gonna
look into and then you know just give
you a sense of how useful this is we're
recently I think your instruments not
performing well you know the resultant
row were higher than central lab because
I was confirming him and so that
actually they they called from the blue
xev be positive bias we plotted all this
data and it definitely seemed like there
is a there's a positive bias overall day
in that one group there was and so by
the way with this message you have
enough data that you can stratify and
color code by
or eventually by instrument so anyway we
separated out two groups that turned out
that one group was was using one
instrument but submitting it to the
wrong code and the group that was kind
of kept it up is actually submitting to
the right code and so now we've got
something a foundation for a
conversation and one last thing I think
I want to say about this the compounds
and biases are a really big concern and
a couple key to Cuates is a tool because
that's diagnostic accuracy study it
that's really useful engine I just want
to point out three of these so number
one what was the spectrum of patients
representative of the patient who
received the testing you don't want to
have a selection bias choosing the rocks
at a patient and that's a possibility so
with glucose when there's sort of a
random pairing of the point-of-care with
the central lab testing it doesn't
matter it's random patient but in a case
where you don't have that much testing
or you don't have a system set up like
we do at troponin in the IDI where there
is an automated confirmation high value
well then you're probably only going to
get confirmation or possibly only
confirmation when there's an unexpected
result which is more likely to be wrong
and you might be getting in worst case
scenario though they are still events
that are occurring you know we are in
accuracy study so another thing is uh
another one thought was important to
highlight is number five did the whole
sample or just a random selection of the
sample received verification using a
reference standard
so this is really important when you're
trying to develop a model that machine
learning model or predict something for
instance so if you want to look at the
accuracy or trying to predict celiac
disease you're starting with the
antibodies the anti tissue
transglutaminase spring you want to make
a model predicting positive biopsy and
of course using the positive biopsies
your gold standard you can look
retrospectively and collect all that
data but the problem is that not every
patient is going to get a biopsy right
first of all you're more likely to get
biopsy if you're anti ttg is high and
then you're more likely to get a biopsy
if it's low but you have other risk
factors though you have an implicit
selection bias here that you need to be
really careful and then the last one I
mentioned is with the reference standard
independent of the index test so did the
index test form part of the reference
now it sounds kind of ridiculous but in
point of Christmas happens all the time
where you know someone's doing a study
with multiple point of care instruments
and then it's a winner-takes-all so
majority vote wins so most of the
instruments vote one way of course makes
it now another one I wanted to talk
about is hemolysis and this is a big
problem it happens a lot more and some
from some units than others and you know
there's a lot of miscommunication wising
all my specimen course we're not he
might
in the pre analytic phase when you're
drawing the blood but with a number of
laboratory so you could simply get a
release high concentration in the cell
potassium or there can be interference
with some of the enzymes in reaction
like a Billy Reuben dilution testing
Cody alysus and so we wanted to look at
mine LS for the impact of hemolysis and
one of the reasons is that we actually
currently report all of our gaseum
regardless of humanness but we report
and we like to switch over to cancelling
some of some results so we need to
decide what level hemolysis warrant so
we decided to go through so we
identified potassium results first that
had the meiosis and we assigned a
hemolysis index to each one now ideally
you would simply have the hemolysis
index in the medical record or LA but we
don't you get this really crazy
statement that card hardly legible but
it's constant it's consistent and so you
can query for that within R 2 then we
identify again near in time non-heme
Eliza fantastic result maybe they sent
in a sample right after because the teen
wise and trusted and they happen to live
so we want to use those pairs to see
what what level amount this is causing
elevation of potassium that's concerning
we had to did this found about 6,700
hemolysis advanced and by over 500,000
and looks something like this so this is
looking at samples collected within 60
minutes of each other and the h-index is
the our laboratory systems method of
assessing how much amounts it's so 2 3 &
4 are increases and he unreported it's
you see an average we're getting a ship
about three but we can do a little
better and create essentially what is a
lookup table so on the x axis here is
the index the tascam Rizal you're
concerned about on the y axis is an ear
and time on hemolyzed event and you can
see here and we color coded by hemolysis
so the grey button there's no analysis
and you can see there you get a nice
correlation curve about what you'd
expect there's a little bit of variation
there which is you know imprint
imprecision and puts it in
instrumentation but probably the fact
that 60 minutes had elapsed graph but
then as you increase hemolysis you see
like those in red it's as flat so with
marked analysis even if you have a half
team of eight or ten there were no
events that were above the critical
values except one and you are going to
see this with messy data but that
particular patient I looked at it it
appeared as though the anima lioness
paired event would actually he lies if
this wasn't recorded properly because
there's a blood gas performer at the
same time that you know and then this
red one down here with an IV dilution
so with this data now we can have an
informed discussion about which tax what
level analysis we should not report so
the last thing I wanted to talk about is
modeling and I want to talk about it
because you can pull wonderful
information and data out of the health
system to inform your houses and improve
it but you and when you're making models
it's really important not just to look
you know if you're looking at
Diagnostics don't just look at
sensitivity and specificity if you want
to know how a diagnostic is going to
impact the patient outcome you not only
look you have to look at you know the
issues the functions degree which have
to do with the test the accuracy within
the laboratory at the time I'll turn
around you also need to look at how
those tests are going to impact the
diagnosis and if a diagnosis is impact
in fact that's not quite enough you also
need to management change and then you
need the drug to work so there's a lot
of steps they have to be successfully
completed before diagnostic now here's a
really I want to show you guys two
models one a very simple one and one and
then a more complicated ones this is
studied by Brad Caron his colleagues are
using their method this is our data this
is a histogram of glucose values these
decision limit and so what this means is
these are all decision limits where
you're promoting
minister now this is assuming that all
the results are perfectly accurate well
what if you add on bias and imprecision
eh result then they might shift it might
cross over into a different across the
my crossover decision limit and cause
you know the inappropriate so what they
did was they body added bias on the
y-axis and imprecision on the x-axis and
then in implied of these these lines
showing the rate you know or a given
imprecision and given by it what percent
of cases we misclassified by three
categories not one or two but over three
different categories and so when you do
that and in place your meter are
occurring somewhere there and it's
consistent with what I've been finding
pretty accurate now if you look at the
actual instead of baseness an estimate
the bias and precision just look at the
actual paired events that we have see
how many point-of-care tests missed
hypoglycemia for instance there's 364
hypoglycemic event in the central lab
those were met by the poincaré
instrument but they were just over the
edge of it and in the end only two of
them would have been given that were our
only two would have been given insulin
now you get to more sophisticated models
by looking at cost-effectiveness and so
this is the cost effect in this plane or
space we have cost and effectiveness on
different axes and of course you want to
have great effectiveness and low cost
but you plot all of your different
scenarios or strategies on the plane and
then can make a decision about which one
you want to use but you can use this to
ask questions like how much you will be
willing to pay for a more rapid
turnaround and see the testing or how
predictive of a positive biopsy tooth
and ATPG screening need to be and so the
actor
so there are many approaches this but
two common approaches are decision trees
and micro stimulation so a decision tree
is is simpler you know it's not like
you're and of course right you start off
with scenic testing and then your two
strategies on the left and behind demand
PCR is one strategy and analyzes another
strategy and and then in that point is a
certain chance that the patient will
will either have see the infection or
not there's certain chance that the
tests will be positive or not leading to
the final terminal know the true
positives false negatives true negative
and positive and you put a cost on those
events and and then you know what
percent of population falls in each
category and then you can roll the model
back and get sort of what your average
cost a micro simulator - I'm showing you
data an HIV disease progression model
building this is Africa but you know I
wanted to mention this in the context of
India not only because it's useful to
synthesize big data but it big data
itself so it's some of the heaviest
computational needs I have to run this
model if I start you start with an
initial cohort and that's that's shown
on the on the left here and we have
healthy patients HIV undiagnosed HIV
drug naive HIV on heart one our second
Lion Heart and in such your initial
population and then you you marvelous
month by month over like ten to thirty
years and all along you're tracking
things like there's a testing event
maybe or medication change and you're
tracking their viral load and how the
viral load is
you can see the [ __ ] count and a low
cd4 count predisposed to an opportunist
infection or death and so doing this
it's easy to say alright we're going to
add some air into the or we're going to
change the algorithm it's supposed to be
I'm using two different brands in you
know a parallel testing approach but
maybe there's using one brand because
the other moments out of stock and so
what's the impact that those kinds of
decisions have accuracy miss diagnosis
of HIV now on top of that you want to
get a sense of uncertainty and so what I
am etre like there's a distribution and
so then you need to run the simulation
many times and this is it this is done
processing and so when you do that you
see on the right here you can track your
different patient your cohort and so you
see right away this is looking at the
test entry strategy where you're
immediately treating anyone regardless
of cd4 count and so immediately a lot of
people go on to hard with prior
diagnosed patients and that continues to
go up and it starts to drop eventually
and that was going on hard on second
line is starting to increase you can see
those are drunken Heath is decreasing
and then you synthesize all that to look
at your question of interest so in my
case I'm looking at and in the impact of
retesting frequency and positive
diagnosis so if you diagnosed multiple
if you're testing over and over again
you know the high-frequency annually and
you got your specificity as a touch low
well you're going to end up
the literature's actually showed and so
this is looking at the impact of testing
and then finally and you can take that
data and put it onto the cost effect in
this plane like this so costs on that X
and y-axis is quality adjusted light
here and green is high quality testing
and orange is the current or low quality
and so you with this data you can get a
sense of how much it's costing the
health system to you know have a sort of
current low quality testing and also how
many adjusted life years are you gain
all right well that's what I wanted to
share with you I want to acknowledge the
people so with interval generation um
Sarah cool and [ __ ] shot stanford
machine learning and encoded data that's
you know releases work with his
colleague path informatics here pre
analytic err hemolysis maybe man that
eats resident and volunteers been
working on that with me and then your
accuracy stuff remains there and thank
you for your time
thank you doctor for that informative
presentation and before we get started
on the question and answer session I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're gonna try
and answer as many questions as time
allows doctor our first question is why
is big data and health care taking so
long thank you yes
I think there's a few key reasons for
this I think so with the increasing
paper report performance and capitated
models there's going to be a strong
desire to you know prevent illness in
high cost of care and using the learning
healthcare system and another big
problem is there how you get it out and
and I think maybe one of the problems
there's not a ton of competition between
electronic health records and there's
there's not there's not a strong
eventually you might get there so now
groups are doing it outside of the
electronic health record itself but that
means
you know having to invest in analysts
and so forth hospitals are doing this is
a massive industry right it's 20% of our
GDP in the US and and there's a huge
amount of waste right Don Berwick
published on this models of an wedges
model of inefficiency six categories of
inefficiencies that account for 20% are
probably more of healthcare dollars I
think it's just a matter of time thank
you our next question do you really need
to use all the filtering steps for the
POC accurate Saudis right time stamps
are funny things you see a time stamp in
the medical record you think okay that's
exactly well that's not the case so the
point of care that is the time is when
you submit the result um that's pretty
close but for the central lab it's the
time you print out to label so if you
take a while to get over to the patient
side it's going to look like you I'm
true it earlier and you actually did so
we did a study to actually identify the
delay in time between the label printing
and drawing on average and we use that
adjustment but actually a little bit
worse so I think you could just base it
on time zero assume there's no errors
and then choose your time window the
delays the central lab were a big part
of the bias infected accounted for all
the biases on
the point of care insurance if you care
with a bias they might want to correct
for that but you could also just know
that that's probably causing about five
MiG's per deciliter on average you're
taking about an hour to turn on your
book posted in the central lab the
arterial lining made very little
difference and we did that of course
because if a result came from a finger
stick and you're comparing to a arterial
line sample or venous line sample and
the a lines made a little difference I
think because location pretty much
accounted for all that once we admitted
it to the ICU that's their location and
and then the other thing I want to
mention about this is it's just the bias
that you might get when there's not a
built in meta system for confirmation so
you have to be concerned about results
centralized results being ordered simply
because there's an unexpected point care
result in there next question how are we
supposed to do this I don't know are and
I don't have access to data from the M
or EMR
right yeah so if you're interested in
this you can make progress I think the
first question you have to ask is is
which data you need so is the day there
going to be an electronic medical record
or the laboratory information system if
you're in pathology and clinical
Diagnostics then you're going to have
easy access to the laboratory
information system and what's beautiful
about that is all the data is formatted
and and that's really special because
it's easy to work with the medical
record there's some formatted fields
like icd-9 code but but most of it is
free text and then you got there
worrying about national natural language
processing or annotating the medical
record you know doing it by hand new
chart reviews so anyway that's an
important first step but you know some
things though the laboratory information
system is real imited you have formatted
data and objective data but you don't
have information typically like so
you're going to have to have a contacted
both in most institutions I think have
you know an analytics service that will
repeat and if you're not my experience
here analysts are one of the fastest
growing positions and so you can seem to
find where they are are they also a
quality division and a lot of people
asking them for help but if you have a
compelling question
I think you can get someone to help you
succeed and you know I think try in our
class it's a there they're all over the
place
do you mind course arrow and other
Hopkins has some really good our classes
at a free tank you know if you do this
and you've got you know computational
sort of skill set it'll really help you
spread your winnings and thank you I'm
very intrigued by the famine work what
are the biggest obstacles to making it
happen so I you know the biggest problem
facing creation of machine learning
model is so I I was creating model for
celiac disease and it required me you
know how quickly or how many conditions
you create model the greatest problems
to be solved in this informatics field
which is the automated you know typing
icd-9 coding is known to be imperfect
can you automate phenotyping with
electronic health record data so that
cohorts could be automatically generated
and then you could just run machine
learning algorithms on any clinical data
you happen to have access to on these
phenotypes and create models constantly
and sometimes the machine learning part
of it is the easy part and once you have
your data in the right format you can
use our to run any number machine
learning algorithms is a different
selection of a function but you can also
find player panelists or engineers who
are interested in this you wanna have
access to data and want to help out so I
think that the key thing is the clinical
question and creating a clean gold
standard and you know that's the key and
then of course you're going to need to
interface the lis to in our server and
to require all right thank you
and we do have time for one last
question can you really trust models
aren't they so dependent on your
assumptions that you can lead to nearly
any conclusion you want
so somebody's yes and and so I think
that the bottom line is that is that you
shouldn't take just the headline of a
modeling paper I think that you know
models are completely dependent on the
assumptions that's that's true and the
real value of modeling is achieved when
you're working closely with the
decision-maker and sort of iteratively
adjusting the model to look at different
scenarios performing sensitivity
analyses different how that impact
things yeah I think it is very dangerous
just to read the headline on a modeling
paper factor that's how if you
implemented their strategy and your
health system that's that you experience
the same outcome
so it's it's really a decision support
tool and not one of my decision analysis
professors would say that that all
decisions you make are made with
uncertainty and the advantage of
modeling is that you're explicitly
stating that thank you for the question
thank you doctor for answering all of
the questions here that we have time for
do have any final comments for today
I just I urge interested yeah
those in the healthcare system that are
interested in in this kind of work
taking advantage of all that data that's
sitting in the health record just every
time you come up with a problem you're
facing just think what could we solve
this through a data mining approach most
of time you answer is no but
occasionally you run into it yes you
know and you identify those projects you
know have an arsenal and then you're at
some point it's worth it right to to go
through the process of learning how to
get access to the data and finding
people who are in a collaborate with you
to analyze it if you don't want to
analyze it to yourself but you know it's
just a really exciting world to be
involved with and try to I thank you
again doctor for your outstanding
presentation and for your answers to
today's questions I'd also like to thank
lab roots for making today's edge of the
educational webcasts possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2017 you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to Ford that
announcement to any of your colleagues
who have may have missed today's live
event until next time goodbye